สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่นกันค่ะค่ะ
แล้วก็ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้อง
เรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน comprehensible
ไทยค่ะอ่าก็เป็นห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบ
ธรรมชาตินะคะใช่ค่ะอ่าแล้วก็วันนี้เรามา
เจอกันอีกแล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กวันเนี้ยเรามาเจอ
กันในวันอะไรคะใชวันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันพุธ
แล้วค่ะนะเป็นวันพุทธค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันนี้วันที่ 24 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
มกราคมค่ะนะโหทำไมครูบีนับนับเยอะจังเลย
เดือนที่ 1 ปีพ.ศล่ะคะ
2567 ค่ะค่ะปีค.ศล่ะคะ 2024 ค่ะวันนี้
เนาะครูปุ๊กครูบีก็มาพบกับทุกคนในวันพุธ
ที่ 24 เดือนมกราคมปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะค่ะก็วันเนี้ยใช่มเป็นวันพุธ
แล้วก็เป็นเดือนที่ 1 ด้วยแต่ครูเนี่ย
โอ้โหคิดว่าน่าจะเดือนที่ 5 นะไม่ใช่ค่ะ
เพิ่งจะ Happy  New  Year ใช่มยแล้วเราก็
เริ่มต้นในเดือนมกราคมแต่วันนี้ก็ 24
แล้วนะครูปุ๊ก
อืมกราคมเดี๋ยวก็บ๊ายบายใช่ค่ะตอนแรกคิด
ว่าครูบีจะบอก Happy
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
Birthday ยังค่ะยังค่ะอ่าถ้าเเดครูบีเ
เนี่ยต้องรอก่อนค่ะอืมอืนะยังไม่อยากอายุ
มากขึ้นค่ะครูุอืครูบีพูดแบบนี้รู้สึก
สะเทือนค่ะรู้สึกไม่ไม่ดีใช่มั้ยรู้สึก
ไม่สบายใจเอ้าก็ทุกคนเนี่ยก็ต้องเกิดไง
ครูปุ๊กแน่นอนเออแล้วครูบีเกิดเนี่ยเกิด
ที่ไหนคะเกิดที่บ้านที่โรงพยาบาลพี่สวน
สาธารณะ
ไม่สบายใจเลยนะครูปุ๊กพูดแบบนี้นะคะออก็
ไม่รู้ไงว่าอาจจะแบบคุณแม่กำลังเดินเล่น
ออกกำลังกายอยู่แล้วก็ปรากฏว่าโเจ็บท้อง
แล้วก็อุอออกมาเป็นครูบีหรือเปล่าโครูบีเ
เนี่ยเกิดเนี่ยมีโรงพยาบาลแล้วนะคะ
อืเอ้าก็เกิดที่โรงพยาบาลค่ะครูปุ๊กก็ครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยเห็นเนี่ยมีฝรั่งเนาะต่างชาติ
เนี่ยบางคนเนี่ยเขาก็ยังไม่ชอบไปคลอดลูก
ที่โรงพยาบาลค่ะเห็นเขาคลอดที่บ้านอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็มีพยาบาลมาที่บ้านแล้วก็
ช่วยดูแลทำคลอด
อาฮะนะแต่ที่ประเทศไทยเราก็ไม่ค่อยเห็น
แบบนี้นะเราจะเห็นว่าถ้าเกิดว่าครูบีท้อง
ใช่มยต้องแต่งงานก่อนเนาแตนแทนแทแท่ะครู
บีแต่งงาน Accident ไม่ได้เหรอคะโรแมนติก
กับสามีแล้วท้องต้องโรแมนติกด้วยนะอือ๋อ
แล้วครูบีเนี่ย 9 เดือนใช่มยูต้องไปโรง
พยาบาลเพื่อคลอดลูก
อืแต่ถ้าบอกฮัลโหลคุณหมอมาที่บ้านเนี่ย
เออน่าจะแพงนะ
ุใช่ค่ะก็น่าจะแพงอยู่ค่ะนะแต่ว่าแน่นอน
แหละในสมัยก่อนไม่มีโรงพยาบาลเนี่ยหรือ
ว่าตามหมู่บ้านที่อยู่ไกลๆจากโรงพยาบาล
เนี่ยเขาก็อาจจะมีคุณหมอเนี่ยทำคลอดแต่
ว่าเป็นแบบไม่ได้เรียนหมอแต่เป็นผู้หญิง
ที่อาจจะเคยทำคลอดเยอะๆนะหรือว่าคลอดลูก
เยอะนะก็เป็นหมอเหมือนกันเราเรียกหมอตำแย
เนาะอืมทำคลอดที่บ้านในสมัยก่อนถ้าเป็น
หมอตำแยที่ทำคลอดผู้หญิงที่ท้องเนี่ย
เมื่อก่อนประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีเยอะอยู่แล้ว
ค่ะกูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะเนาะแล้วก็พอมาหลังๆก็คือ
ตอนเนี้ยเรามีโรงพยาบาลเยอะมากแล้วแล้วก็
คนที่ทำงานเป็นหมอตำแยเนี่ยก็อ่าหมดไปค่ะ
ค่อยๆหมดไปนะเพราะว่าอายุมากแล้วแล้วก็
ไม่มีใครทำต่อนะแล้วก็ก็เด็กเดี๋ยวนี้
เนี่ยก็คลอดโรงพยาบาลก็จะรู้สึกว่าง่ายๆ
ไงเพราะว่านะไม่ต้องดูแลมากแบบเนาะเพราะ
เรื่องความสะอาดอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแบคทีเรีย
ไวรัสเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าเชื้อโรคนะนเชื้อ
โรคมันเยอะนะจะทำแบบเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยน่าจะ
ไม่ไหวะนะก็ไปโรงพยาบาลก็ง่ายกว่าค่ะ
อ่าก็ก็ต้องไปโรงพยาบาลเนาะปัจจุบันเพราะ
ว่าแต่ถ้าเป็นสมัยคุณแม่ครูบีเนี่ยก็คลอด
ที่บ้านค่ะเห็นมนะแล้วก็แล้วโรงพยาบาลน่ะ
รูบีคิดว่าเามีความปลอดภัยอยู่แล้วถูก
มั้ยแต่
ใช่แต่แต่หมายถึงว่าเอ่อเราคลอดเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยเราจะได้ลูกของเรากลับคืนมาใช่มั้ย
เอ้าทำไมครูปุ๊กพูดอย่างงั้นล่ะคะก็ไป
คลอดลูกที่โรงพยาบาลเออที่โรงพยาบาลเนี่ย
พอคลอดลูกเสร็จลูกเนี่ยร้องโอ้แวโอวเนี่ย
เอ่อลูกก็นอนอยู่กับเรามั้ยอันนี้ครูบี
ไม่รู้เพราะครูบียังไม่เคยท้องนะคะก็จะมี
แบบเอ่อโรงพยาบาลเขาก็จะมีห้องเนอรี่เนาะ
หรือพยาบาลเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอาเด็กเนี่ยไปทำ
ความสะอาดไปเช็ดตัวไปจัดเนาเพราะว่าเด็ก
เด็กอ่ะจะมีคราบมีเป็นน้ำคร่ำเลอะเทอะเขา
ก็จะไปทำความสะอาดค่ะรูบีนะแล้วถึงบางโรง
พยาบาลถ้าเป็นเอกชนเขาจะมีเลี้ยงไว้ใน
ห้องเนรี่คุณแม่ไม่ต้องเลี้ยงแต่ถ้าเป็น
โรงพยาบาล
รัฐบาลราคาไม่แพงเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอาออกมาให้
คุณแม่เนี่ยเลี้ยงเองอือืนะแต่ว่าทีนี้
เนี่ยที่ครูปุ๊กบอกว่านะเราจะได้ลูกตัว
เองเนี่ยกลับมาเลี้ยงหรือเปล่าเนี่ยหมาย
ถึงว่ามันมีข่าวค่ะ
นะข่าวครูปุ๊กอ่านที่ไหนค่ะที่
อินเทอร์เน็ตหรือว่าที่ทีวีคะที่
อินเทอร์เน็ตค่ะนะอืเป็นข่าวเกี่ยวกับ
อะไรอ่ะครู
ปุ๊กก็เป็นข่าวเกี่ยวกับนะผู้หญิงที่ไป
คลอดลูกเนี่ยละค่ะครูบีผู้หญิงไปคลอดลูก
ไปคลอดลูกคือผู้หญิงเนี่ยท้องแล้วก็ไป
คลอดลูกไปคอดลูกที่ไหนคะที่โรงพยาบาลแต่
ว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้ที่ครูบุ๊กอ่านเนี่ยไม่
ใช่คนไทยค่ะนะอ้าเป็นคนประเทศมาเลเซีย
อืมนะแล้วก็สามีภรรยาใช่มั้ยแตนแนแๆแต่ง
งานเนี่ยผู้หญิงท้องโอโหโอเคมั้ย 9
เดือนโอ๊ยแต่ผู้หญิงคนนี้ต้องท้องใหญ่
กว่านี้ค่ะครูบีทำไมอ่ะเพราะว่าเค้ามีลูก
แฝดค่ะ
อ๋อเออเนาะลูกแฝดเนี่ยท้องต้องใหญ่มาก
เพราะว่าลูก 1 คนเนี่ยท้องก็ใหญ่มากแล้ว
นะแต่นี่เป็นแฝด 2 คนหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
นะก็ผู้หญิงคนเนี้ยเขก็ไปโรงพยาบาลเพราะ
ว่าเจ็บท้องแล้วก็ไปคลอดลูกนะเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยลูกก็คลอดออกมาค่ะ
นะอตึงเป็นฝาแฝดผู้
หญิงใช่ค่ะเป็นฝาแฝดทั้งเป็นผู้หญิงทั้ง 2
คนค่ะนะอเห็นมั้ยเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นแฝดแบบ
เนี้ยเราเรียกว่าแฝดแท้
อืมคือฝาแฝดเนี่ยเวลาเราคิดเนี่ยหน้าก็จะ
เหมือนกันใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็เป็นผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงเหมือนกันหน้าเหมือนกันอออ่าครูบีคือ
อย่างงี้นะฝาแฝดเนี่ยเราต้องบอกก่อนว่า
เป็นลักษณะแบบนี้ก็คือถ้าเกิดว่าหน้า
เหมือนกันแบบเนี้ยก็คือจะเป็นลักษณะเรา
เรียกว่าแฝดแท้ค่ะแฝดแท้ก็คือจะมีไข่ใช่
มั้ยของคุณแม่อือืแล้วก็มีอสุจิอสุจิ
เนี่ยหรือว่าสเปิร์มของคุณพ่ออค่ะนะไข่ 1
ฟองสเปิร์มหรืออสุจิ 1 ตัวนะแล้วก็เข้ามา
ผสมกันแล้วก็เกิดการแบ่งอแบ่งแยกออกมา
เป็น 2 นะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นแฝดที่ถ้าเป็นผู้
หญิงก็เป็นผู้หญิงทั้ง 2 คนถ้าเป็นผู้ชาย
ก็เป็นผู้ชายทั้ง 2 คนอ๋ออ้อเพราะว่าฝา
แฝดเนี่ยก็จะมีหลายแบบเนาะที่เราเห็นแต่
ถ้าคือผู้ชายกับผู้ชาย 2 คนเป็นแฝดผู้ชาย
เนี่ยก็คือแฝดแท้ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็แฝดแท้
ใช่ก็คือว่าจากเกิดจากไข่ฟองเดียวนะแล้ว
ก็ไข่กับสเปิร์มอย่างละ 1 เท่านั้นแล้วก็
เกิดการแบ่งตัวออกมาเป็น 2 คนซึ่งบางที
อาจจะแบบแบ่งแบบไม่สมบูรณ์ก็ได้เนาะมัน
อาจจะแบบออกมาแล้วอาจจะตัวติดกันเหมือน
เหมือนแฝดสยามอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะที่อย่าตัว
ติดกันอืมเนี่ยค่ะอันเนี้ยคือแฝดสยามที่
มีชื่อเสียงของคนไทยเนาะอินกับจันอย่าง
เงี้ยก็คือเาเนี่ยถูกแบ่งแต่ยังไม่
สมบูรณ์ 100% แต่เกือบละมีติดกันอยู่นิด
เดียวอืม
นะแต่มันก็จะมีแฟตเทียมอืนะแฝดเทียมก็คือ
เกิดจากไข่ 2 ฟองนะเกิดจากคุณแม่อาจจะมี
ไข่ตกพร้อมกันใน 1 เดือนปกติ 1 เดือน
เนี่ยไข่จะตกแค่ฟองเดียวนะจะสลับกันซ้าย
เดือนนึงขวาเดือนนึงซ้ายเดือนนึงขวาเดือน
นึงเกิดมีแบบมาทีเดียว 2 ฟองอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะทีนี้ก็เกิดเอ่ออสุจิเนี่ยมันก็เข้าไป
เจาะไข่เนี่ยก็คือจะเป็นอสุจิ 2 ตัวอืม
อ่าแล้วก็พอเกิดไปผสมปุ๊บ
นะก็เลยเกิดการเป็นแฝดนะแต่ไม่ได้เกิดจาก
ไข่ฟองเดียวกันไม่ได้เกิดจากสเปิร์มตัว
เดียวกันนะมันก็เลยอันเนี้ยเค้าก็เลย
เรียกว่าแฟตเทียมนะแฝดเทียมก็หน้าอาจจะ
ไม่เหมือนกันเพศอาจจะไม่เหมือนกันเพศก็
คือผู้หญิงผู้ชายเนาะนะบางทีมันก็จะเป็น
ผู้หญิงคนนึงผู้ชายคนนึงเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
หรือเป็นผู้หญิงกับผู้หญิงผู้ชายผู้ชายก็
ได้แต่หน้าอาจจะไม่เหมือนกันก็ได้อืก็เลย
มีแฝดแท้แฝดเทียมแบบเนี้ยค่ะค่ะก็บางที
เราก็จะเห็นว่าอ่าเด็กที่เป็นฝาแฝดบางคน
น่ะเป็นฝาแฝดนะเขาบอกเนี่ยเป็นฝาแฝดของ
ฉันแต่เป็นผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงเอ่าใช่นะก็
มันก็ไม่แปลกอะไรเนาะคนที่มีลูกแฝดเนี่ย
เพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยเค้ามีบรรพบุรุษนะที่
เมื่อก่อนคนเมื่อก่อนก็แบบอาจจะมีลูกแฝด
แล้วก็ส่งนะ DNA ส่งสืบทอดมาทางนะให้ลูก
ให้หลานต่อไปก็มีแฝดได้ค่ะมีโอกาสมีลูก
แฝดฝาแฝดอืก็ธรรมดาแหละเพราะว่าบางคนคุณ
ปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายใช่มั้ยคุณพ่อคุณแม่
เนี่ยพอมาสู่รุ่นรุ่นลูกก็อาจจะมีแฝดฝา
แฝดนะใช่ค่ะนะแต่แต่ทีนี้เนี่ยมันมันที่
มันมันไม่มันไม่นี่ก็คือว่าเกิดจากการทำ
งานผิดพลาดของเจ้าหน้าที่โรงพยาบาลค่ะ
เพราะว่ามีอีกครอบครัวนึงที่มีคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่แล้วเขาก็มาคลอดลูกสาวเหมือนกันแต่ลูก
สาวเนี่ยไม่มีฝาแฝดค่ะเป็นคนเดียวลูกสาว
คนเดียวแต่คลอดวันเดียวกันนะแล้วก็เวลา
เนี่ยใกล้กันนะเนื่องจากว่าคนที่เป็นฝา
แฝดเนี่ยก็จะคลอดครั้งเดียวแะ 2 คนไม่ได้
ก็ต้องออกมาทีละ 1 คนบางทีก็จะเบรคใช่มย
ไม่รู้กี่นาทีก็จะออกมาอีก 1 คนอย่าง
เงี้ยอือ่าแล้วบังเอิญว่าอาจจะเป็นเพราะ
ว่าเด็กคนเนี้ยก็คลอดมาในช่วงเวลาที่ใกล้
กันก็เลยทำให้พยาบาลเนี่ยอาจจะทำงานผิด
พลาดเนาะสมมุติอ่ะคนนี้คนที่ 1 คนนี้คน
ที่
2 อันนี้เป็น a เนาะจะได้ไม่มี
B บียังไม่ท้อง
ค่ะนะแล้วก็ทีนี้เนี่ยปรากฏว่าพยาบาล
เนี่ยสลับเด็กค่ะไม่รู้เกิดอะไรขึ้นเจ้า
หน้าที่โรงพยาบาลเนาะนะสลับเด็กคือ 2 กับ
a
เนี่ยกลับบ้านเนี่ยไม่ได้กลับบ้านตัวเอง
ค่ะหื 1 ก็เลยถูกเลี้ยงดูมากับ
a นะเพราะว่าอ๋อคือพยาบาลเนี่ยอาจจะเอา
เด็กใช่มยเพราะว่าอันเนี้ยครูบีก็ไม่รู้
ว่าเวลาคลอดเนี่ยเขาอยู่รวมกันอย่างนี้
มย
คืออันนี้เนี่ยน่าจะเป็นการให้นมเฉยๆใช่
แต่เวลาที่ที่อยู่ห้องรวมกันให้นมเสร็จ
อาจจะเอาเด็กพยาบาลอาจจะเอาเด็กไปไว้ที่
ไหนหรือเปล่าคะครูปุ๊กเอ่อถ้าเป็นห้องแบบ
นี้เนี่ยส่วนมากเค้าคุณแม่เลี้ยงเองอืนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยโอกาสสลับเนี่ยบางที
เนี่ยไม่ค่อยมีเพราะว่าเด็กเนี่ยจะถูกส่ง
มาให้เลี้ยงเลยใช่มั้ยคุณแม่ก็จะเลี้ยงคน
เดียวเลยแล้วก็ดูแลลูกตัวเองพาไปอาบน้ำ
เองอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะก็อาจจะไม่ได้สลับหรือ
ว่าตอนที่คลอดออกมานะเจะมีป้ายชื่อของคุณ
แม่ค่ะ
อืมป้ายชื่อของคุณแม่ว่าคุณแม่อยู่เตียง
ที่เท่าไหร่แล้วก็ชื่อนามสกุลอะไรแล้วก็
ใส่บางทีใส่ที่แขนเด็กบางทีใส่ที่ขาของ
เด็กนะจะได้รู้ว่าคุณแม่คือใคร
อืแต่ก็แปลว่าผู้หญิงมาเลเซียเนี่ยลูก
เนี่ยอยู่ในห้องห้องเด็กเหรอคะ
เอ่อเราก็ไม่ไม่รู้ว่าเ้าสลับกันตอนไหน
อาจจะเป็นตอนที่พยาบาลเนี่ยเขียนชื่อแล้ว
ก็อาจจะป้ายชื่อเนี่ยสลับกันหรือเปล่านะ
หรือว่าไปสลับตัวกันตอนที่เอาเด็กเนี่ยไป
ทำความสะอาดอืก็อาจเป็นไปได้เนาะเราก็ไม่
รู้นะคะเพราะว่าก็จะมีผู้หญิงครอบครัวที่
ครูปุ๊กบอกเนี่ยก็คลอดลูกเหมือนกันใช่ค่ะ
เเนี่ยแล้วเอาอาจจะอุ้มไปวางผิดพี่ใช่
มั้ยอืก็ไม่รู้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเนาะเพราะ
ว่าจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยตอนที่กลับบ้านเนี่ยนะ
แทนที่จะเป็น 1 กับ 2 กลับไปด้วยกันก็
เป็น 1 กับ a เนี่ยไปอยู่บ้านนี้อ๋อคือ
สลับบ้านสลับ 2 เนี่ยไปอยู่บ้านเนี้ยอืนะ
ก็เลยกลายเป็นว่าเด็กเนี่ยที่ถูกเลี้ยงดู
มาเนี่ยคนที่เป็นฝาแฝดเนี่ยใช่มั้ยจริงๆ
อ่ะครูบีบอกเอ้ยหน้าต้องเหมือนกันอันนี้
เค้าหน้าไม่เหมือนค่ะอืมก็นึกว่าเป็น
เหมือนเอ้าก็เมื่อกี้ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าถ้า
หน้าไม่เหมือนก็เป็นแฝดเทียมได้ใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไม่
สงสัยค่ะไม่ได้สงสัยว่าเอ้ยลูกฉันหรือ
เปล่าทำไมหน้าไม่เหมือนกันนะเอาจจะเป็น
แฝดเทียมหน้าไม่เหมือนก็ได้ใช่แล้วก็ยัง
เบบี้เนาะยังแบบเป็นเด็กทารกก็ยังดูไม่
เข้าใจนะตอนอยู่โรงขยับอืก็ไงอ่ะ 2
ครอบครัวเนี่ยก็ไม่มีใครสงสัยเลยนะ
อก็เลี้ยงดูมาต่างคนต่างก็เกิดมาแล้วก็
เลี้ยงดูกันนะจนโตขึ้นเนี่ยทีนี้เนี่ยตอน
เด็กๆเนาะไอแล้วอยู่มาคลอดโรงพยาบาลเดียว
กันแสดงว่าอาจจะอยู่หมู่บ้านอาจจะคนละ
หมู่บ้านอาจจะแบบนะอยู่โรงเรียนก็ไม่ได้
อยู่โรงเรียนเดียวกันค่ะอืมแต่อยู่ใน
ละแวกอาจจะแบบไม่ไกลกันมากอืนะทีนี้เนี่ย
ก็เด็กเนี่ยก็เข้าโรงเรียนก็เรียนนะชั้น
ระดับชั้นเดียวกันเพราะอายุเท่ากันเนาะนะ
ก็พอตอนที่ขึ้นไฮ School แล้วมัธยมปลาย
เนี่ยอืปรากฏว่า
a นะก็เอ้ย 1 อ่ะเขาก็ต้องไปทำกิจกรรม
เป็นแบบไปเข้าค่ายลูกเสือ
เนตรนารี
อืเป็นกิจกรรมที่โรงเรียนเนาะอ่าก็เรียน
ลูกเสือนะ
คะใช่ค่ะคือเค้าเคยเรียนค่ะอืมอ่าใช่มั้ย
ถ้าเป็นผู้ชายก็เป็นลูกเสือถ้าเป็นผู้
หญิงก็เรียกว่า
เนตรนารีอืนะแล้วก็ต้องไปเข้าค่ายนะเป็น
แคมป์อ่ะแบบเป็นค่ายพักแรมอืมนะต้องนอน
ค้างใช่มยแล้วก็จะมีตัวแทนของโรงเรียนโรง
เรียนโรงเรียนเนี่ยนะ 1 โรงเรียนก็อาจจะ
ส่งไปแบบ 30 คน 50 คนแล้วแต่เนาะนะก็
ปรากฏว่า 1 เนี่ยเขาก็ไปนี่เค้าเป็นผู้
หญิงต้องใส่ชุดแบบนี้ค่ะอืนะเนตรนารีผู้
ชายเป็นชุดอันนี้ลูกเสือค่ะ
นะก็พอไปเนี่ยก็เข้าค่ายพักแรมเนี่ยก็
ปรากฏว่าได้รู้จักเพื่อนคนละโรงเรียนอืนะ
ก็ได้เจอกันกับเพื่อนคนอื่นๆแล้วเพื่อน
เนี่ยเค้าก็บอกว่า 1 ทำไมอ่ะ 1 เนี่ยหน้า
เหมือนเพื่อนมากๆเลยอืความสูงก็พอๆกันอื
เออหน้าตาก็เหมือน
กันเออเหมือนกันมากเขบอกบอกอย่างงี้
นะ 1 ก็อ้าหรอไหนขอดูรูปหน่อยสิเหมือนแค่
ไหนเพื่อนก็เลยเปิด instagram ของนะ
เพื่อนที่ว่าหน้าเหมือน
1 แล้วก็ให้ 1 ดูพอ 1 ดูเนี่ย 1 ก็
เอ้อทำไมเหมือนเหมือนรูปตัวเองจังเลยทำไม
เหมือนตัวเองมากทำไมหน้าเหมือนฉันมากใช่
มั้ยก็ตกใจใช่มั้ยใชก็เลยขอ
Instagram เพื่อนเพื่อนก็ส่งให้ใช่มยนะ 1
เนี่ยพอเข้าค่ายภักแรมเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็
กลับบ้านใช่มยพอกลับบ้านก็ไปคุยกับคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่อืนะคุยกับน้องใช่มยอืนะน้องฝาแฝด
นะซึ่งจริงๆตอนเเป็นเอยังอยู่ที่บ้านใช่
มยก็เลี้ยงมาด้วยกันอก็คุยว่าเออเนี่ยมี
คนหน้าเหมือนกันเลยน่าเหมือนฉันเลยนะแล้ว
ก็คุยกันพ่อแม่ก็ไม่สนใจค่ะอืก็โอเค
เหมือนก็เหมือนนะคนหน้าเหมือนก็มีเยอะแยะ
ไปออคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็ไม่ได้สนใจใช่นะแต่
ปรากฏว่าก็เลยเอ่อเราก็บอกว่าติดตาม Ig
เนาะก็ติดตามแบบนะ 1 ก็ติดตามดูว่าเอ๊ะคน
เนี้ยหน้าเหมือนเราเนี่ยเคทำอะไรมั่งวัน
นึงวันนึงเคชอบอะไรเค้าทำอะไรชอบกินอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยนะเด็กๆก็ชอบลงเนาะนะก็เลยรู้
อาจจะโพสต์ IG บ่อยๆเล่นอินเทอร์เน็ต
โซเชียลใช่มยใช่แล้วพอไปดูเนี่ยก็หลาย
อย่างที่มันเหมือนๆกันชอบเหมือนๆกันนะอ
เค้าก็รู้สึกแปลกใจเหมือนกันแล้วก็พอถึง
วันนึงคือวันเกิดอืนะคนเนี้ยเขาก็โพสต์ IG
ว่าวันเกิดเค้าทำอะไรบ้างมีเพื่อนมา Happy
Birthday อะไรอย่างเงี้ยพอหนึไปดูก็เอ้า
เกิดวันเดียวกันอีกอืมเอ้าหน้าก็เหมือน
ฉันวันเกิดก็วันเดียวกันกับฉันอ่าโอหก็
มันแปลกเริ่มเริ่มรู้สึกส่งากรู้ใช่มั้ย
แล้วก็ติดตามมากขึ้นอ่าใช่มยแล้วก็มาคุย
กันกับน้องใช่มยก็คือเอที่เป็นคิดว่าเป็น
แฝดแล้วก็คุยกันว่าเฮ้ยเนี่ยเขาเกิดวัน
เดียวกับเราเลยนะนะแล้วก็คุยกันปรากฏว่า
เออวันที่มีโอกาสไปเจอกันจริงๆอ่ะก็คือ
มันเค้ามีงานเกี่ยวกับเรื่องการการศึกษา
หรือการเรียนนะของโรงเรียนในเหมือนทำ
กิจกรรมอ่ะนะ
ในในอาจจะเป็นจังหวัดนะแล้วก็เหมือนแบบ
อาจจะแบบเหมือนเรียนมหาวิทยาลัยจะเรียน
คณะอะไรดีอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะเค้าก็ได้มาเจอ
กันค่ะอันเนี้ยเจอจริงๆเจอหน้า
แบบพอเห็นหน้ากันหน้ากันใช่ครั้งแรกที่
เจอหน้ากันเนี่ยทั้ง 2 คนก็ตกใจอ่ะอื
เพราะว่ามันเหมือนมากอืนะเขาก็บอกว่า
โอ้โหทุกคนก็บอกว่าเหมือนจริงๆใช่มอืนะ
เพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่าเด็กๆพอจะเข้าเรียน
ระดับมหาวิทยาลัยเนี่ยเขาก็จะเชิญเด็กๆ
เนี่ยอาจจะไปทำกิจกรรมแล้วก็ไปฟังเนาะอ่า
มีคนที่มีประสบการณ์ก็จะมาแนะนำว่าไป
เรียนที่ไหนดีอย่างเงี้ยก็หลายๆโรงเรียน
ก็อาจจะมารวมตัวกันก็เลยได้โอกาสเจอหน้า
จริงๆได้เจอกันเลยใช่ค่ะเนี่ยค่ะเห็นมย
คืออันเนี้ยถูกเลี้ยงกับ 1 ใช่มยเป็นฝา
แ8
แต่พอไปเจอเอ้าทำไม 2 คนเนี้ยที่วงกลมเน
สีแดงนะทำไมหน้าเหมือนกันมากอืมากกว่าฝา
แฝดอเก็ถ่ายรูปปู้กันใช่มันก็เลยยิ่งทำ
ให้สงสัยเพราะว่าเกิดเนี่ยโรงพยาบาลเดียว
กันนะวันเกิดวันเดียวกัน
อืมก็เลยทำให้เด็ก 3 คนเนี่ยก็เลยคุยกัน
ว่าอืมตรวจ DNA มั้ยเช็ค DNA กันมั้ยนะ
รู้เด็ก
ๆใช่เพราะว่าไปถามคุณพ่อคุณแม่คุณพ่อคุณ
แม่ก็บอกว่าไม่ต้องตรวจหรอกเพราะว่าเค้า
ก็กลัวเนาะว่าถ้าเกิดว่ารู้ว่าเอ่อเอสลับ
ตัวกันอแล้วทำยังไงอ่ะอืนะความผูกพันที่
เลี้ยงมาเนาะนะถึงไม่ใช่เลือดตัวเองไม่
ใช่ลูกตัวเองเนี่ยนะแต่เลี้ยงมาตั้งแต่
เล็กตั้งแต่เป็นเบบี้อย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็
เด็กทารกใช่มั้ยนะแล้วก็โตๆๆมาจน 19 ปี
อ่ะอืโหแล้วจะให้พ่อกับแม่ทำยังไงใช่มยนะ
แต่เด็กเด็กอ่ะเขาก็อยากรู้เหมือนกันว่า
เพราะว่ามันดูแล้วเนี่ยหน้าเนี่ยมันไม่
เหมือนกันใช่มยแล้ว 2 คนหน้าเหมือนกันน่ะ
มันก็อาจจะมีการผิดพลาดมาจากโรงพยาบาลก็
ได้ไงนะคือเด็กทุกวันนี้เค้าก็เก่ง
เทคโนโลยีเนาะเาสามารถที่จะเสิร์ช Google
ดูโรงพยาบาลเช็คข้อมูลได้ก็แปลว่าเด็กๆ
เนี่ยอยากรู้ความจริงใช่ก็เลยไปตรวจ DNA
ค่ะ
อืมผลออกมา
ก็อย่างที่คิดค่ะอืมอย่างที่คิดเพราะว่า
แสดแท้เนี่ยหน้าเนี่ยจะเหมือนกันเป็นเพศ
เดียวกันอยู่แล้วนะแล้วก็หน้าเนี่ยจะ
เหมือนกันเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็เกิดจากการ
ผิดพลาดของโรงพยาบาลที่สลับตัวเด็กนะไม่
รู้จากตรงไหนเนอะนะก็เลยทำให้เด็กๆเนี่ย
เารู้ความจริงว่า 2 กับเเนี่ยสลับตัวกัน
มาอืม
นะแต่ว่าอแล้วอย่างงี้คือเค้าโอเคมั้ยกับ
โรงพยาบาลหรือไม่มีปัญหาคือจริงๆก็ไม่น่า
จะโอเคแต่มัน 10 กว่าปี 19 ปีเกือบ 20 ปี
เนาะคนที่ทำงานก็ไม่รู้ยังอยู่มั้ยอืนะ
แล้วก็ไม่รู้ผิดจากตรงไหนด้วยนะการเช็คหา
ก็อาจจะยากลำบากเนาะนะแต่ว่าก็ยังยังดี
ที่ว่าเหมือนกับว่าเออก็มันก็ไม่ได้ดีนะ
คือจริงๆแล้วอ่ะคุณแม่คุณแม่ของเอเเนี่ย
เาเสียชีวิต
อืตั้งแต่ 2 ปีก่อนที่จะเช็ค DNA อ่าก็
คือคุณแม่ของเอไม่อยู่แล้วนะคะก็ไม่ได้
รู้ความจริงใชใช่นะเอก็เลยไม่ได้มีโอกาส
ได้ไปรู้จักคุณแม่ตัวจริงเนนะส่วนคุณพ่อ
ก็เสียชีวิตเหมือนกันหลังจากเช็ค DNA
แล้ว 2 เดือนอืมนะคุณพ่อก็เสียชีวิตอืเ้า
บอกว่าอย่างงั้นนะแล้วก็ 3 คนก็เลยมาอยู่
ด้วยกัน
ก็คือจริงๆน่าสงสารเอมากเลยนะแต่เอก็ยัง
โชคดีที่มีครอบครัวที่เป็นฝาแฝดก็เอาเอเ
เนี่ยมาอยู่ด้วยเพราะว่าคุณแม่ก็เสีย
ชีวิตคุณพ่อก็เสียชีวิตอือืนะก็อันนี้ก็
เป็นแบบเอ่อก็ก็ในโชคร้ายนะโชคร้ายก็คือ
คุณพ่อคุณแม่เนี่ยเสียชีวิตหรือตายนะใน
ความโชคดีก็คือเค้าก็ได้อยู่กับครอบครัว
เดิมที่เลี้ยงเขมาตั้งแต่เล็กเออใช่เนา
คิดว่าคุณพ่อคุณแม่ที่ไม่ใช่คุณพ่อคุณแม่
จริงๆเนี่ยก็รักเนาะเพราะว่าเลี้ยงตั้ง
แต่ตั้งแต่เกิดอืมใช่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมัน
มีความผูกพันนะความผูกพันเนี่ยก็คือความ
รู้รู้จักกันรู้รู้สึกเห็นอกเห็นใจรู้สึก
รักรู้สึกนะมันก็เลยทำให้แบบครอบครัวก็จะ
รักกันได้ไม่ยากแล้วคนที่เป็นฝาแฝดกันน่ะ
นะยังไงเนี่ยความรู้สึกอ่ะมันจะผูกพันกัน
โดยโดยธรรมชาติของการเป็นฝาแฝดอืมแล้ว
แล้วถ้าเราดูในรูปนี้ก็คือ 2 คนเนี่ยเป็น
ฝาแฝดใช่ใช่มั้ยปุุใช่ใช่คนที่ค 2 คนนี้
ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะอันนี้คือ a ใช่มั้ยใช่
อืมเค้าก็กลายเป็นว่ามี
เพื่อนมีเพื่อนเข้ามานะคะเป็นพี่น้องกัน 3
คนแต่อันนี้คือเป็นแฝดแท้หน้าเหมือนกันนะ
แค่สลับตัวกันใช่มั้ใช่ค่ะสลับตัวกันอืนะ
แต่ก็อย่างน้อยที่ที่สุดเขาก็ได้รู้ความ
จริงไงว่าเค้าเนี่ยนะเป็นฝ่าแฝดกันจริงๆ
เนาะกับอีกคนนึงเนี่ยที่เอาไปเลี้ยงดู
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ฝาแฝดนะอืก็ความรักก็น่าจะมี
ให้กันอยู่อ่ะเนาะนะใช่แล้วก็คิดว่าฝาแฝด
แล้วก็อีกคนนึงเนี่ยเขาก็ยังรักกันนะก็
คิดว่ามีความผูกพันแล้วก็เป็นเพื่อนรัก
กันเป็นพี่เป็นน้องกันได้นะคะคือสลับตตัว
อุยอันนี้ที่โรง
พยาบาลใช่ค่ะครูบีอันเนี้ยจริงๆไม่ใช่
เกิดแค่ที่มาเลเซียที่ประเทศไทยก็เคยเกิด
ค่ะนะเคยเกิดเหมือนกันอันนั้นก็อายุ 15
ค่ะถึงได้รู้ความจริงเหมือนกันนะก็มาจาก
โรงเรียนเแหละค่ะที่นะเหมือนเวลาไปเรียน
แล้วเรียนระดับเดียวกันเพราะอายุเหมือน
กันเนาะแล้วก็มีโอกาสได้เจอกันมันทำให้
ทุกอย่างเนี่ยมันเออมีความสงสัยไงนะว่า
ทำไมคนที่อยู่ด้วยเนี่ยหน้าไม่เหมือนอื
แต่ว่าคนที่แบบไม่ได้อยู่ด้วยกันเนี่ย
หน่าเหมือนนะมันก็เลยทำให้เป็นเหตุทำให้
คนเนี่ยเขาไปเช็ค DNA ไงครูบีอืเนาะอัน
นี้ก็ไม่ว่าจะเป็นโรงพยาบาลนะคะหรืออ่า
การทำงานต่างๆเนาะบางทีมันก็ผิดพลาดได้นะ
คะคะถ้าเกิดออกมาเนี่ยเป็นเด็กทารกยังพูด
ไม่ได้หน้าเนี่ยก็เหมือนๆกันไงครูปุ๊กใช่
ไม่ว่าจะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ผิวขาวผิวดำเรก็แล้ว
แต่เนาะนะลูกเกิดมาเนี่ยเค้าก็แดงๆอ่ะแบบ
ตัวสีแดงๆแล้วก็แบบหน้าตาก็แบบเหมือนยัง
ไม่ได้มีเนื้ออะไรมากใช่มยนะก็มองยังไม่
รู้หรอกค่ะว่าหน้าเหมือนใครอืก็อาจจะเห็น
สติ๊กเกอร์ชื่อเนี่ยผิดค่ะใส่ที่ข้อมือ
ใส่ที่ขาเนี่ยก็อาจจะผิดพลาดได้นะคะอัน
นี้ก็เป็นเรื่องของฝาแฝดนะที่สลับตัวกัน
ที่โรงพยาบาลนะสลับตัวกันตั้งแต่เกิดเลย
นะอืใช่ค่ะนะก็โชคดีว่าเป็นฝาแฝดก็เลยหา
คู่ฝาแฝดเจอแต่ถ้าโดนสลับโดยที่ไม่มีแฝด
เนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่ได้รู้เลยก็ได้นะใช่นอก
จากว่าคุณพ่อคุณแม่จะเป็นคนสงสัยว่าทำไม
ลูกฉันเนี่ยโตขึ้นโตขึ้นหน้าไม่เหมือนพ่อ
หน้าไม่เหมือน
แม่นะวันนี้เราก็คุยกันเกี่ยวกับเรื่องฝา
แฝดที่สลับกันนะคะใช่ค่ะตั้งแต่เด็กแล้ว
ก็เดี๋ยวโอกาสหน้าครูุจะหาเรื่องเนี่ยมา
เล่าให้นักเรียนฟังอีกเนนะันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วเราก็ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะค่ะวันนี้ก็ขอลา
นักเรียนแล้วก็สวัสดีครูปุ๊กค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย